da die fußballwelt ist unter schock
steht unter trauer denn diego maradona
ist tot er soll im alter von 60 jahren
gestorben sein zuhause und mehr dazu
weiß matthias marburg jetzt bei mir im
studio matthias was weißt du genau
wissen wir schon etwas über die
todesursache ja die nachrichten sind
ganz frisch die kamen relativ frisch
rein
twitter hat vor kurzem angefangen mit so
explodieren wirklich auch der nachricht
es ist wohl so dass er in seinem haus in
tiger einen herzstillstand erlitten hat
und darf für tot erklärt wurde und das
im alter von 60 jahren hatte gerade
geburtstag
er war auch vor kurzem schon im
krankenhaus gewesen gab es einen
blutgerinnseln im hirn ich weiß nicht ob
die zuschauer die bilder gesehen haben
wie er dann ins krankenhaus gefahren
wurde mit den fans die auf den
krankenwagen geklopft haben und bengalos
auf dem weg gezimmert haben und so
weiter und so fort und auch als
entlassen wurde hat dasselbe rückwärts
praktisch die fans wir ihnen wieder
gefeiert
ja das frage glaubst du da gibt es einen
zusammenhang weil eigentlich war er
gerade er auf dem weg der besserung
es gab entwarnung wir haben die ersten
szenen gerade angesprochen wir haben die
bilder noch im kopf wie wirklich der
arzt umzingelt wird von den fans und
alles anfangen zu jubeln als ja es geht
ihm besser
es gibt jetzt keine arzt ich kann es
nicht genau sagen was der zusammenhang
zwischen einem grinsen im gehirn und
einem herzstillstand ist ich würde jetzt
spontan erst mal keinen erkennen aber
wenn man mal donna denkt dann denkt man
halt immer auch an gesundheitliche
probleme der vergangenheit an seinen
drogenkonsum an diverse verfehlungen die
er gesundheitlicher art hatte es gibt
die anekdote als er einmal in
herzstillstand hatte vor 15 jahren
ungefähr da wahre im krankenwagen und es
gab kein krankenhaus in buenos aires das
ihn aufnehmen wollte weil kalk ein
krankenhaus das krankenhaus sein wollte
indem er stirbt die wehr krankenwagens
zwölf stunden durch die stadt gefahren
bis sie endlich ein krankenhaus gefunden
haben dass ich seine erbarmt hat und ihn
dann auch gerettet hat damals lass uns
noch mal ein bisschen über sprechen was
maria für ein weltfußballer wir haben ja
gerade diese jubelszenen angesprochen
vor dem krankenhaus als es ihr besser
ging was wird jetzt quasi in der dose in
argentinien das jetzt nach dieser
meldung dass diego maradona gestorben
ist also was war das für ein fußballer
fußball dabei einer der größten aller
zeiten überhaupt keine frage er war
weltmeister argentinien zum weltmeister
geführt das ist das was ihnen
von vielen argentinien auch von messi
unterscheidet man sagt maradona war ein
löwe messi ist er ein kaninchen weil
messi es nie geschafft hat die
nationalmannschaft zu großen erfolgen zu
führen sondern immer nur seine
vereinsmannschaften und bedeutete den
bin lieben sie halt in argentinien eben
wegen dieses weltmeistertitels den er
ihn geholt hat sie verteilen ihm alle
fehltritte die danach zahlreiche im
leben hatte und er ist ein idol für viel
es gibt eine eine kirche kirche von 10
also seine rückennummer die zähne gibt
eine kirche die sich gegründet haben hat
man so einen spaß kirche aber die hat
mehrere zehntausend mitglieder
wenn man in argentinien unterwegs sieht
man überall bilder von maradona auf auf
postern irgendwie auf auf brückenpfeiler
gemalt alles möglich also er ist das
idol in argentinien und argentinien geht
gerade durch eine sehr schwere
wirtschaftliche krise und jetzt noch der
tod von maradona hat das ist glaube ich
ein sehr sehr schwerer schock für ganz
ganz viele argentinien und wissen wir
schon ob sich die verwandten von ihnen
verabschieden konnten wir hatten es ja
letztens erst bei udo walz da haben wir
dann gehört dass sich der ehemann auf
grund von corona nicht verabschieden
konnte das weiß ich nicht was ich aber
sagen kann ist dass meine kollegin
silvia rolle letztens mit seinem
biografen gesprochen hatte hat der
biograf halloween ski gesagt dass
madonna zeit nicht mehr aus dem haus
geht weil er halt angst vor corona hat
und auch relativ wenig besuch bekommt
deshalb denke ich dass es der familie
nicht möglich war sich von ihm zu
verabschieden
er hat glaube ich neun kinder zuletzt
hat er erst die vaterschaft für drei
kinder anerkannt die er während seiner
drogen rehabilitation oder entzugs
aufenthalt in kuba gezeigt hat ja und
ich gehe davon aus dass sich die verlage
für familie nicht von ihm verabschieden
konnte mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren